[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: --GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
IKAI LAN: Good morning
from New York.
Welcome to yet another edition
of Apps Script Live.
My name is Ikai Lan, and
this is Kalyan Reddy.
He's a new member of our team.
Kalyan.
KALYAN REDDY: Hi, guys.
IKAI LAN: Why don't you tell
us a little about yourself?
KALYAN REDDY: I started here at
Google about two and a half
weeks ago on the Apps Script
team, and I'm very excited to
start working here.
Seems like a great product,
and I'm learning more
and more every day.
I hope to share that
with you guys.
IKAI LAN: Kalyan's a new member
of our team, so you're
going to start seeing him more
in these office hours, as well
as the Stack Overflow
Issues Tracker.
You'll be seeing a lot more of
his face and his remarks.
So Kalyan, tell us a little
bit about yourself.
Tell us a little bit about
yourself technically.
What's your favorite programming
language?
KALYAN REDDY: I work mostly with
Java, but if I want to
whip up something quick, I like
to go the Python route.
IKAI LAN: Anything in
particular, any libraries or
frameworks that you like
in Java in particular?
KALYAN REDDY: I like
them all, man.
IKAI LAN: You like them all!
Wow.
Because, man, I can name
some monstrosities.
KALYAN REDDY: I've been living
for the last two years in the
cold, cold land of Minnesota,
so there wasn't much to do
except for go online
and program.
So, hey, that's my background.
IKAI LAN: Cool.
Well, welcome to
New York City.
New York City's happy to have
you, and you're going to have
a blast out here.
So we've got a great show
for you guys today.
Before we start, I am always
plugging events.
We're doing an Apps Script
Hackathon in Los Angeles.
We had such a great
time in Austin.
We announced it a few weeks ago,
and I will be plugging it
every time on this show, because
I'm going to be there.
I don't think we've decided if
you're going to go or not.
KALYAN REDDY: I'd like to go.
IKAI LAN: Hey, we'd
love to have you.
And we're going to have Arun,
who you saw on the show a few
weeks ago, will be attending,
as well as we'll be having
some members of the
[INAUDIBLE] team.
So go on Google and search
for Apps Script
Hackathon, Los Angeles.
It should be one of
the first results.
And if Google's working
correctly, my face should show
up next to the blog post.
It's happening on Tuesday,
November 3, in our Google
Venice Beach office.
Venice Beach is where Arnold
Schwarzenegger used to work
out, and that's where he got his
career before he had his
breakout hit in Conan.
So maybe we'll have
a break out there.
KALYAN REDDY: Maybe.
IKAI LAN: Hit the beach,
and maybe some famous--
KALYAN REDDY: Of course.
We're going to film some slow
motion montages, and upload
that to the developer
[INAUDIBLE].
IKAI LAN: Slow motion montages
of us coding.
That's great.
You know what?
One day they're going to make
a movie of people actually
programming, instead
of when you see
these movies of people.
Oh my God, so exciting!
They have these three worlds.
KALYAN REDDY: They can
have the music
from Chariots Of Fire.
IKAI LAN: It's going
to be so terrible.
It's just going to be switching
windows and using Vim.
But enough procrastinating.
We're making Eric
laugh too much.
So Eric, who I'm usually on this
show if he's producing
for us today.
Eric, say hi.
ERIC: Hi.
IKAI LAN: I don't know
if you heard that.
He's shy, anyway.
No, he's not shy.
So we've got that Hackathon
coming up.
Just go on Google, search
for Apps Script
Hackathon Los Angeles.
It's in our office.
We're going to have
food and drinks.
It's going to be a lot
of fun, right?
So why don't we go ahead
and get started.
We're going to talk a little
bit about a recent release.
We'll go through some of the
Q&A, and if we have any live
audience members, let's talk.
So let's start with some
of the release notes.
KALYAN REDDY: All right.
Can you guys see this?
IKAI LAN: There it is.
KALYAN REDDY: So I think for
these release notes, the only
thing I'd like to really
stress is that we are
validating HTTP as
certificates now.
So if your app is doing a lot of
URL fetch requests, and you
see some flakiness, you would
want to set that to false.
IKAI LAN: Set the
value to false.
KALYAN REDDY: Set the
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
So what's happening is we had
a recent release last week.
Was the 21st last week?
Yeah, it's last Thursday.
And there's a couple of new
features, so check them out on
search for Apps Script
release notes.
But there's one thing that's
very important that everyone
should know is that if you're
using URL fetch app at all, we
were not validating HTTPS
certificates.
So a lot of places, they let
their HTTPS certificates
expire, and this is
not intentional.
I have been at places where we
ask people, I'm like, wait, do
we have to renew this cert?
And the guy next to me goes,
oh, I think we do.
KALYAN REDDY: We should do
that one of these days.
IKAI LAN: Oh, yeah.
It's so common that a
certificate will, like, you'll
forget to renew your
certificate.
It's a human error.
And I remember one time we
didn't do it, because we put
it on our calendar, and we're
like, oh, we're not going to
forget this.
Then the company made us switch
calendaring systems.
So we're like, why isn't
it in our calendar?
And it's very common.
But if you're seeing that
you're making a call,
obviously it's not secure,
because you're opening
yourself up to what's called
a man in the middle attack.
And a man in the middle attack
is if I'm sending you a
message and Eric intercepts
it, and he
rewrites stuff, right?
Because Eric is very
mischievous.
Very mischievous guy.
He can actually intercept and
read the messages, and pass
them back and forth.
KALYAN REDDY: I really
don't trust Eric.
IKAI LAN: Wow.
I think there's a line there
that you just crossed.
No.
But the HTTP certificates,
definitely the default is
safe, which is validate
your certificates.
But if there is a site that you
know you can trust, you
could set to false, because
sometimes you just want to.
Sometimes you don't care if
there's a man in the middle.
You're just getting some data,
and it's like public, right?
But we leave that up to you
to make that choice.
So, how do you feel
about some Q&A?
KALYAN REDDY: Sounds good.
Let's get to it.
IKAI LAN: Let's do it.
I love your enthusiasm That's
why I'm happy to have you on
this team, because of your
enthusiasm for Q&A.
KALYAN REDDY: Let's see here.
So, the first question we have
is, I have a library
containing a webApp
(UIApp/doGet) intended to work
with each user's spreadsheet.
How can a user of that library
pass the ID of his own
spreadsheet to the library?
So there are a couple ways to do
this, and I quickly coded--
IKAI LAN: Let's clarify
the question first.
When I read this, I initially
misunderstood.
I thought he was asking us if I
am building UIApp, how can I
ask the user for
a spreadsheet?
And that's why I misrepresented
the question to
Kalyan when I was talking
to him earlier.
I said, oh, yeah, because it
really sucks to have to
copy-paste an ID from a URL
bar and take it into this
webApp and put it into
a text field.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
That would be a bad
user experience.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
I mean, if you're whipping up
something fast-- like, we have
a bunch of scripts in-house
that do that, but that's
because we're, like, I run the
script once a month and I know
how to use this thing, right?
But it doesn't look like that's
what you're asking.
It looks like you're building
a UIApp to get in a library,
and you want a user to be
able to use that UIApp.
I think that's my
understanding.
Is it yours?
KALYAN REDDY: That's
why I got as well.
And so, if that's what you'd
like to do, there's several
ways to do this.
One of the things is I quickly
coded up a script here that'll
accomplish it.
Obviously, you can link to the
library here, and then once
you do that, in order to get
your docs list, you can just
use our docs list API, and you
do get files by type, and you
pass in the enumerated type
for a spreadsheet.
It'll get all your
spreadsheets and this variable.
You iterate over it,
and you can get ID.
Or there's also functions where
you can search by name.
You can query for the actual
spreadsheet that you're
looking for, and once you have
that ID, you can just go ahead
and pass it into whatever
library function, let it to do
its thing, come back, and
it presents the results.
Other things that you can
potentially do is you don't
necessarily need to have
this be done in code.
You can call these same
functions and have the results
display in a list, a Dropbox,
something that people can
visually see and select, and
that would make it easier for
them to just take whatever
file name that they want.
You can correspond that file
name to an ID, and then do
your thing in the background.
IKAI LAN: Right.
That's good.
But from a library perspective,
my assumption is
that you're trying to build a UI
and return it, and return a
UI app instance.
So you would likely
create a method.
We call these builder methods
inside your library that says
build a UI from spreadsheet
ID.
And from that, if you're
building this library, I would
call this library, and inside
this builder as a parameter, I
would pass the spreadsheet ID.
That is how I would do that.
Or I would say what's containing
spreadsheet, right?
There's a bunch of different
ways of doing this, and I
think what Kalyan is saying is
that it depends on what it is
you're trying to do.
If you really want to build a UI
as a library, I think there
are a lot of challenges when
it happens, right?
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, you don't
generally want to do that.
I think it would be cleaner to
do it just the other way,
externally.
Just use the library to just
have functions that you can
query and get results and
responses quickly.
And do you have any examples
to clarify that?
IKAI LAN: A good example is if
you should be able to build
like a widget, and add
it to your UI, right?
Custom widgets and whatnot.
Yeah.
So, let's go on to some
more questions.
KALYAN REDDY: All right.
IKAI LAN: Let's see, is there
anyone live on the
Hangout right now?
We've got a different set up.
Hi, there.
I guess we'll come back to it.
I just wanted to see
if people were on.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
IKAI LAN: Oh, hi.
KALYAN REDDY: There we go.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
IKAI LAN: How are you?
AUDIENCE: Pretty good.
I actually had a related
question to that question.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, why
don't we take it?
Because it seems
to make sense.
AUDIENCE: I've been using the
new library functionality a
lot, and we have scripts that
go into our corporate
database, pull out data,
display that, make
charts, and so forth.
And we do a lot of setting what
we did before the script
properties.
We would set the name
of the database.
We'd set the name of the
table, and so forth.
The user would go into a UIApp
and select what data source
they would want.
But now, if I'm using a library,
and I moved all of my
functionality, the JDBC
functionality, in the library,
I don't know where it's now
stored, those values for each
user in the calling
spreadsheet.
I can't use script properties
anymore, because that will set
it one time for the
whole library.
Right?
If I set the database name, for
example, I have functions
which build queries, then put in
the database name into the
queries, the JDBC call.
So if I do it as a script
property, then every user
would overwrite each other's
database name, right?
IKAI LAN: So script properties,
there are a couple
different things.
There's a script property which
is global to the script
itself, and there's also this
concept of the user property,
which is, I think, what you
may be looking for.
Now, the tricky thing is--
yeah, the user property
will work fine.
So if you set something using
user property, that's
something that's only set for
me running the script.
So I could set a user property
that says here's my JDBC
information, go to town
on my database.
And Kaylan could have a
different one that says
userproperty.set or
userproperty.get.
Now, it's still in the
same properties UI.
You go to the UI, and you'll
see that, OK, I have the
script properties that are
global to the entire script,
as well as user properties
which are just
local to just me.
And that's what you probably
want to do in this instance.
AUDIENCE: Had a problem
with that, too.
That's what I was just trying
half an hour ago.
IKAI LAN: What was the
problem you ran into?
AUDIENCE: User properties are
global to that user across all
of their scripts in our
domain, it looks like.
But I have a set of 12
different, similar scripts, so
when a person goes and uses
another spreadsheet, it
overwrites it on there.
So I kind of need the
combination this
user for this script.
IKAI LAN: I see.
So this functionality is going
to get a bit more complex.
If you want to do it per user,
per spreadsheet, or script
[INAUDIBLE]
whatever it is you're doing, and
this is where ScriptDb is
going to be useful.
So we're working on an article
about ScriptDb how to do this,
how to do get by key
and set by key.
But what you want to do is
you can at any time call
session.geteffectiveuser.
Not activeuser,
geteffectiveuser.
The reason you want to use
effectiveuser is because
geteffectiveuser will return
the user that the script is
running as, and you could do
getemail and key off the
user's email.
And what you do is you build a
script to be instanced where
you say here's the user, here
is the spreadsheet ID, and
[INAUDIBLE].
You store that inside ScriptDb,
and you pull that up
whenever you need this
information.
So you've got a lot of
different options for
persistence.
ScriptDb, think of it as it's
kind of like a document store
for your entire script,
but because you can
programmatically control what
data you want from it, you can
say, well, this user is Eric,
and the spreadsheet ID is 123,
so I want the database that
corresponds to Eric and script
123, and that's where you
can pull back your JDBC
information.
AUDIENCE: Great.
And then in my library, I
would just need to use a
function that pulls out what
is the ID of the calling
spreadsheet, right?
IKAI LAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How would I do that?
IKAI LAN: I don't know this
off the top of my head.
AUDIENCE: But it exists?
IKAI LAN: What's that?
That function exists?
IKAI LAN: I think so, but
I need to double check.
It's not
getcontainingspreadsheet.
It wouldn't be named what I
think it's named, because I
name my stuff weird.
I think there should be a
method that calls that,
because your script is running
inside the spreadsheet.
You can find the containing
spreadsheet, and you should be
able to find the container,
as we call it,
and dig out the ID.
But I'll need to double
check on that for you.
So, if you want, post on Stack
Overflow and I'll follow up on
that question.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks a lot.
Excellent.
IKAI LAN: Is there anyone
that's live?
And if you're not live, feel
free to jump onto our Hangout,
developers.google.com, and
click on the Events tab.
You'll see Apps Script Office
Hours, and there should be a
button to jump on the Hangout,
or watch the broadcast.
Let's move on to some of the
questions in the Moderator.
KALYAN REDDY: All right,
here we go.
Let's refresh and see.
IKAI LAN: I just heard a sound
like someone jumped on
[INAUDIBLE].
He's playing, like, the
William Tell Overture.
I like classical music.
KALYAN REDDY: Prequel
to our [INAUDIBLE]
Los Angeles.
IKAI LAN: What do we got?
KALYAN REDDY: All right.
So, the next question we have
is, to reduce round trips,
original values can be read
from the sheet to array.
When he played it in script,
written from array to sheet.
What about cell format settings
on certain cells
identified in my script?
Can I bundle those
into a single
round trip is the question?
IKAI LAN: Cell format settings
on certain cells.
So, I guess what you're asking
is is there a way you can
batch formats on
certain cells?
I don't think so.
I mean, I haven't seen
an API for this.
I mean, I have to look what the
API are calling now, but
if there's no API for doing a
batch setting or batch format
fetch, then there isn't
necessarily an
easy way to do this.
So I guess the question is why
are you trying to reduce the
round trips?
I understand that round trips
do add some overhead, and
sometimes you can't get around
it because of the API
limitations, so what you end up
needing to do is figure out
how to make your script run
faster, because it's important
that your script appears
to run fast.
So if you want to reduce the
number round trips, obviously
you want to reduce that as much
as possible, but when you
find that you can't, a common
pattern that some people do is
they'll start trigger.
Because a trigger will be
running in the background, and
that'll just make something
happen.
And with triggers, what you can
do is you can effectively
get around various deadlines
by what we call chaining
triggers, right?
So you create a trigger, it runs
some code, and after it
does some certain amount of
executions, it creates a new
trigger 10 minutes later that
follows up and just keeps
running this code.
So this is effectively how
you would do a very
long running job.
Now, we're looking at ways of
making it so that we can
remove deadlines for things in
general, because that'd be
really cool.
I mean, managing triggers, and
rescheduling, and dealing with
the fault tolerance, it's
really annoying.
But that's one way to
get around this.
So I guess that what we want to
do is we figure out what it
is you're trying to do here, and
yeah, see if we can help
you make your app run
buttery smooth.
I stole that from the
Android guys.
Buttery smooth.
KALYAN REDDY: All right.
So do you want to--
IKAI LAN: Sure.
Let's see, we've got a question
from Denmark.
KALYAN REDDY: OK.
So, I'm using a tool to export
spreadsheet data to OpenOffice
spreadsheet files, which
used at a later
time in XML/XMLT toolchain.
Unfortunately, it seems that the
export function of dates
does not work properly since the
dates are saved as floats.
IKAI LAN: Dates are
saved as floats.
Well, I mean, they should be
saved as milliseconds since a
Unix epoch, which is universally
understood.
KALYAN REDDY: [INAUDIBLE]
standard.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
And let's see, the
export function--
using a tool--
is this an Apps Script
tool or--
I don't know what exactly this
is, but if you export as
milliseconds since epoch,
every single programming
language in the world
understands this and has a way
to convert this back
into a data object.
So for instance, in JavaScript,
you would say new
date, and you would pass it the
seconds since epoch, this
number, and it would work.
And you could try this out.
You can say new date zero,
and you'll find it's
like January 1, 1970.
It's like 1979 to '69.
I never remember--
KALYAN REDDY: 1970, I believe.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
Epoch is one of these really
funny things that if you're
not a programmer, it causes all
these problems for you.
Like, I was using I think it
was MongoDb, and I didn't
realize that you can save date
before 1970, and I was using
this for like a birth
dates database.
So I was wondering, why is this
guy who's like 40 years
old, why does it only crash for
people who are over 40?
And it turns out that it's
milliseconds since epoch.
So that is what that
float number is.
It probably is working
correctly, because otherwise,
how would you export a date?
There are a million--
oh, your bad.
KALYAN REDDY: Let me post
on a little bit.
IKAI LAN: Because dates can
be represented in lots of
different formats.
In the US, for instance, we
say month, day, year, but
pretty much internationally,
people say--
KALYAN REDDY: It's
other formats.
There's a lot of confusion
that can exist.
So in order to get around that,
we can simply have a
float number that counts
one long number.
You can format it however
you want.
Universal language math.
IKAI LAN: And there's a lot of
background on dates and times,
so I'm sorry if I bored
a bunch of people.
It's very important, though,
because time zones are the
source of so many bugs
in the world.
KALYAN REDDY: They're
important.
IKAI LAN: [INAUDIBLE]
understand it.
All right, let's see
if there's someone
that's jumped on live.
I heard someone jump on.
It sounded like rock
music, or--
nope, just a bunch
of black screens.
OK, well, let's go back to the
Q&A then, unless someone on
the black screen
has a question.
So just so you know, we are
not looking at the chats.
We're not looking
at chat screens.
So if you're typing something
to chat, we're probably
missing it.
Sorry about that.
KALYAN REDDY: OK, So you want
to head to this question?
IKAI LAN: Yeah, sure.
KALYAN REDDY: John from
Washington, DC, asks, can
conditional formatting be
applied from script?
I don't see a method under
the Range class.
IKAI LAN: Is this conditional
formatting for--
OK, this is conditional
formatting for spreadsheets.
Right?
Is conditional formatting--
OK, I know what you're asking.
So, I think what you're asking
is conditional formatting is I
have this spreadsheet my
friends, where if you owe
someone money, you put it in the
spreadsheet, and if you're
owed money, you put
a positive number.
So it's very simple that we have
a conditional formatting
there, where I say if it's
negative, you're red.
KALYAN REDDY: Exactly.
So you can change the formatting
of the cell based
on the values.
IKAI LAN: Right.
Yeah, you should be able to
set a background color.
There's some other things
you can do.
KALYAN REDDY: You can get the
cell, and you can change the
properties of it.
So I believe you can do that.
IKAI LAN: And in fact, running
it from Apps Script, it should
be much more powerful than what
conditional formatting
allows you, because you could
write it in code, and you
could say do this, or
do this, or do this.
But is there something
specifically
you're trying to do?
And just a thing for our
viewers, these types of code
questions, they tend to be a
little bit better in Stack
Overflow for a bunch
of reasons.
When I'm answering these
questions, the first thing I
want to do is go to our API
reference, because, man, we've
got so many APIs now.
KALYAN REDDY: We've got a
pretty extensive API.
IKAI LAN: So, we try to answer
questions about how to design
things, and how to do things
in Apps Script, but when it
comes to individual API
questions, I am not Eric.
I do not have the API reference
in my head.
Eric's laughing.
He actually does have the API
reference in his head.
I've turned and I've asked him
questions, and he goes, oh
yeah, it's set number format,
and you've got three
parameters.
I go, I don't know
how you do that.
I'm just going to go back to
being a normal human person
that doesn't have a superhuman
capability.
KALYAN REDDY: So I think
specifically for this
question, it's asking is there
one particular API function
that'll accomplish
this for them?
We'll have to go back and see if
that's the case or not, but
if not, there's a two-step way
that's just as easy and maybe
more powerful than any of the
already existing condition
formatting tools that
you can do.
And yes, if you can ask in the
Stack Overflow, we can provide
some code examples, something
like that, too.
IKAI LAN: OK.
So, yeah, definitely ask in
Stack Overflow what it is
you're trying to do, and
we can see if we
can help you out.
KALYAN REDDY: Let's
see if there's any
more questions here.
IKAI LAN: I don't think you
need to refresh this page,
because I'm pretty sure it's
updating whenever there's like
a live update.
It's kind of a cool tool.
I wish that we saw more
use of this outside.
Google Moderator, use it.
It's cool stuff.
So let's go back to the
Hangout and see
what's going on.
Anyone in the Hangout have
anything they want to ask us
about or talk about?
AUDIENCE: Just the same
guy that asked before,
if that's all right.
IKAI LAN: If you don't
mind us asking--
I mean, some people, they like
anonymity, but you're not
wearing like a ski
mask or anything.
So where are you from,
what's your name?
Hey, I see a little fella.
AUDIENCE: My son's here, too.
Actually I'm in Croatia,
and we build
lots of internal apps.
We build lots of stuff on the
Google entire infrastructure,
but build a lot about business
intelligence and business
management apps right inside
Google Apps, using Google Apps
Script and lots of stuff.
Now we're moving on to Google
App Engine for more advanced
stuff, really interested.
But there's a few things driving
me crazy, so I just
wanted to ask one
more question.
And I think this is maybe
something that may be an
upgrade, may be an actual bug,
but the cell limits for
spreadsheets?
I had scripts that were working
for a year, JDBC
again, and I started getting
back too much data, can not
retrieve, too much data.
And I do the math, and it turns
out it's 62,000 cells in
the sheet, and it's
only 33 columns.
So is there some other level of
limitation for JDBC calls?
IKAI LAN: JDBC calls--
so, wait.
So you're saying it's getting
back too much data from JDBC?
AUDIENCE: Well, the error
is not descriptive.
When I take the record set--
I take the JDBC record
set, and I
apply it into the range--
that's where the error kicks
off, is when I try to take
that record set from
JDBC and actually
apply it into the range.
IKAI LAN: Interesting.
AUDIENCE: What's really strange,
for example, it was a
production script, so
I had to change it.
I broke it down into four
smaller queries by status, for
example, and the four smaller
ones would work.
So overall, the number of cells
that were being used
were the same.
But have you guys
run across that?
I don't know what it can be.
IKAI LAN: I haven't run across
specifically 62,000.
I'm not terribly surprised.
My guess is that something's
happening where we're holding
the data in memory somewhere.
In general, there are
upper bounds.
I want to believe that Google
has a supercomputer that has
unlimited RAM, but
I don't know if
that's necessarily true.
If you can break it up, and do
your jobs as broken up, it
does add more programmer
overhead, but if it works, I
wouldn't be surprised if it
works better overall.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So some things are just not
number of cells, but the
amount of memory needed
to hold that object.
IKAI LAN: It could be.
It's hard to say.
KALYAN REDDY: How it ties in
the back, I'm not exactly
familiar with those details.
IKAI LAN: Hold on, my leg's
falling asleep.
Yeah.
I got a standing desk recently
at work, and I love it.
Side tangent.
But yeah, 62,000 is not
a magic number.
Like if you told me, yeah, for
some reason, every time I go
over 65,335, 65,336, whatever,
and I'd be like, I think I
know what's going on, but it
doesn't sound like that's the
number you're tripping.
It's probably some kind of
limitation you're hitting.
I do know that spreadsheets,
when they go above a certain
amount of data inside
spreadsheets, things start to
slow down, but the number's
not 60,000.
It's much higher than that.
I don't know the exact number.
AUDIENCE: OK.
One other little question I had
that I think will interest
a lot of people is about the new
library's functionality,
and it seems to me that users
have to have read and write
access to those libraries in
order to be able to use them.
IKAI LAN: I don't think
that's true, actually.
So, yeah, I don't think
that's true because--
KALYAN REDDY: [INAUDIBLE].
IKAI LAN: Yeah, because when
you publish a library, what
you can do is--
Eric's giving me a time
check, we've got
about two minutes left--
is when you publish a library,
and if the library is just
code, then I just need the key
of the library, put in my
project as include libraries,
and the
library should just work.
Now, I'm wondering if you need
additional permissions to do
things, like maybe your library
does a thing with a
specific spreadsheet?
But even then, if the library's
executing as you, I
don't think that that should
cause a problem.
AUDIENCE: Maybe it's touching
script properties or something
like that, and it needs write
privileges to touch script
properties.
IKAI LAN: OK.
That may be.
I'll need to investigate a
little bit more about this.
In general, you should not.
There's a library that I was
using for a while, which was
the Picasa app library, and I
didn't need read or write
access to that.
It was just open
to the public.
So, it might be because of your
editing script properties
or things like that.
But even, I know, the ScriptDB,
you should be able
to access your own ScriptDb if
you're in a library and not
need read or write access.
Like, you don't need read or
write access to my library, is
what I'm saying.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks guys.
IKAI LAN: No problem.
In fact, we'd love to talk to
you more about what you're
doing and cool stuff that's
going on in App Engine and App
Script, and all the cool things
you're doing, but we're
running out of time,
unfortunately.
So, was there anything else that
you wanted to say to our
wonderful audience today?
IKAI LAN: I'm really excited
to start working on the
product and supporting
you guys.
IKAI LAN: To start?
You've been working.
KALYAN REDDY: Yes, yes.
Really get started.
Get some exciting
things coming.
IKAI LAN: OK.
All right.
So, thank you guys for
hanging out with us.
We really do appreciate it.
Tell your friends, right?
KALYAN REDDY: Definitely.
And the Hackathon.
IKAI LAN: Los Angeles
Hackathon.
But tell your friends
about this show.
Tell your friends about
Apps Script.
I mean, this is some seriously
cool stuff, and you can build
some really cool things
really fast.
scripts.google.com, nothing
to install, you
just get things going.
I call it cloud scripting.
KALYAN REDDY: No need to worry
about maintenance,
anything like that.
IKAI LAN: Cloud scripting.
So guys, thank you guys for
joining our show, and we'll
see you guys next time.
So, this is good bye from
me, Eric, and Kalyan.